ladies and gentlemen let me please
welcome to you the star of HBO's Real
Time with Bill Maher please welcome Bill
Maher ladies and gentlemen
okay well I think you know we started a
campaign at the beginning the year to
find one congressman we wanted to flip
because we don't think Congress is
representative necessarily of the people
and it's yours
mr. John Klein we have nothing personal
against him I just don't think he
represents this district of Minnesota
and I'm just going to go through his
voting record and then we can decide if
that's true or not and here to help me
do that is our panel let me introduce
them
oh that's John right he is the executive
director of Minnesota's jobs coalition
my old job
John rule oh she is a columns for
townhall.com her new book is let me be
clear Barack Obama's war on Millennials
and one woman's case for Hope which is
available right down the road I think at
monkey see monkey read is that right
okay Katie Keefer ladies and gentlemen
and the executive director of the
Minnesota no no that's him he is the
former Speaker of the Minnesota House of
Representatives who is now professor of
the University of Minnesota
Steve swig amis enough of the blue team
and now your hometown Minnesota timber
Oh
all right he is the journalist to mark
the whose latest book the divide will be
out in paperback on October 23rd the
same day he launches his new online
magazine called racket Matt Taibbi is
right
Minneapolis Minneapolis resident who
writes for The Daily Beast Adam Murray
Cox
the mayor of Minneapolis Betsy Hodges
as I said I just want to go through the
record of mr. John Klein and find out if
he really represents this district
because John Klein votes with the
Republicans 98 percent of the time
that's pretty much as high as we could
find of anybody and I don't know that
Minnesota has joined the Confederacy
because that's very very high he never
says anything crazy but he votes exactly
like crazy people like Michelle Bachmann
so I want to divide this into four
categories of voting we're going to talk
about the environment we're going to
talk about women we're going to talk
about students and workers so workers
women students and let's call them
breathers let's start with workers mr.
Klein is voted to get rid of the estate
tax many times this is something he's
obsessed with to reduce the interest in
tax for billionaires to zero he wants to
get rid of the National the income tax
and replace it with a 30 percent sales
tax you can imagine how that would go
down with poor people voted to it
against extending unemployment benefits
against the minimum wage against food
stamps against the DREAM Act against any
Mine Safety regulation does that
represent
Minnesota's second
it does I didn't I mean I this district
went for Obama last time it was almost
even but it doesn't seem to me that it's
that conservative it seems more moderate
why does this record reflect Minnesota's
own it
mr. mark it doesn't represent Los
Angeles and Hollywood where you're from
but it does miss Randolph hasty
lakeville Cannon Falls Kenyon those
those are the towns in the second
district and it does his voting record
does represent that because he wants the
balance between representing maybe what
voters think their ideological
affiliation is and voting in the actual
needs of the voters in the district like
there aren't this is not especially poor
district it's not especially rich
district either there aren't a lot of
people they're going to be benefiting
from the income from the getting rid of
the estate tax you know there aren't a
lot of people they're going to benefit
from the policies but going forward
there are people who might and this is a
little bit and there probably are a lot
that doesn't see from voters you seen it
yeah as a millennial I would counter
that and say that he mentioned bail that
he opposed raising the minimum wage well
that actually does hurt teenagers
there's been a congressional review over
the course of 50 years that found that
every time the minimum wage was raised
it hurt teenagers because employers are
unwilling to pay young people who have
no skills and no experience that higher
wage and I know firsthand that if you
have a job when you're starting out in
eighth grade and then continue on that's
going to help you pay for college well
if you had a dummy am very sorry abusing
anything you can pay for
with minimum wage in eighth grade
toward college with your eighth-grade
minimum wage you could go to for-profit
I went to the University of seeing come
as a very expensive zero right here in
st. Claude I went to three three Chad's
in addition to academic scholarships I
was able to save up but the average
young person today won't have that
benefit is what I'm concerned about if
we raise the minimum wage because they
won't be able to get those jobs done on
who who studies you believe about the
minimum wage everybody has their own
studies about this and United State
University of Chicago says that you know
by a four to one margin that that most
people who are analyzing this topic
believe that when you raise the minimum
wage it has no affect unemployment
whatsoever and also if I may say it used
to be the case that the McDonald's
worker was a teenager now the average
age of the McDonald's worker is 29 ok
these are people with families trying to
live on the minimum
that is the sad fact about the jobs that
we're talking about increasingly we have
to make sure that these jobs can even
begin to afford it you know life for a
family I'm just raising the floor on
poverty is what Steve Jobs wage yeah
that's a good point but Steve Jobs you
mentioned that these people are older we
don't want 29 year olds 30 year olds for
yields working at McDonald's Steve Jobs
is a Democrat and he's told Obama if you
want to create jobs you should cut taxes
and cut regulations and bring talent
into this country outside of the
politically correct framework of the
DREAM Act and so I'm saying let's look
to Steve Jobs a Democrat and do that to
create better jobs for older see I am
all for looking to Steve Jobs may he
rest in peace but also I think I do
think you're conflating two issues when
you talk about the need to save money as
a minimum wage working teenager and the
need for college there's college
affordability which is a major problem
and then there's trying to pay for
college with minimum wage which you
shouldn't try to have to do the minimum
wage in the minimum wage I think what
we're saying and I think some people the
odds are saying is that raising the
minimum wage is not about helping young
people unfortunately it's about usually
helping those young people's parents
I think that it's good that you bring up
that that average age of minimum wage is
there because it's been really
disappointing that over the last six
years what we've seen is that the jobs
that have come back that we're lost in
the recession particularly here in
Minnesota pay an average of $3,000 less
per year than the jobs that were lost in
the recession so we need to take a look
at how we can write our economy
jump-started again and get folks into
those jobs that pay an honest wage for
an honest day's work we need to work on
getting people up and lifting them out
of poverty rather than focusing but
essentially let a job but all all the
games from the ending the recession
coming back have gone to the top with 10
percent the bottom 90% has lost this is
the
mr. martyr be fair to be fair you would
also have to mention that congressman
Klein has worked in a bipartisan effort
with the Senate Democrats on workforce
development issues workforce development
programs very very strong work and the
issues you mentioned most of those most
of those have some type of a of a budget
number address to them assigned to them
yeah and and no actually in the second
District we believe very strongly that
we ought to balance the federal budget
and the deficit wants to balance it he
wants to balance it on the backs of the
students is how we
to the students in a minute but first
let me because you mentioned me from
being from California all right I have a
stake in what happens to John Klein
because John Klein wants to open up
California beaches to drilling that
involves me so I have every right to
come here and talk about John Klein Oh
John Klein top five contributors are all
from out of state so if it's about being
from in-state
these campaign contributors are
for-profit colleges which are not from
Minnesota and coal mining which is not
done here in the second District of
Minnesota why doesn't he take money from
people right here why does it all come
from people who are out-of-state it all
come did you say it all comes that's
wrong I said they even minor dollars so
I don't think a doll came not all okay
not all this worth I think the people in
this district are getting what they're
paying for in the sense that the people
who aren't with people who are paying
for John Kline are getting their money's
worth the people here who voted for him
that didn't give him very much money are
Jeff he's just getting their votes and
not in and not giving it back anything
in return let's move on to do well let's
talk about this environmental record of
his what I call the breathers he is
voted against allowing the Pentagon to
even study climate change he's for
blocking federal oversight of fracking /
he's for prohibiting the EPA from
regulating greenhouse gases I thought
that was their job prohibiting the EPA
from regulating water quality standards
against any limits on co2 pollution
against tax credits for renewable energy
against issuing water quality standards
for relaxing coal mining regulations for
preventing the EPA from managing
Superfund sites again their job against
requiring companies to disclose toxic
chemicals in drinking water what does he
have against breathing
that record in Minnesota in particular
is is in affront to the fact that we
have so many natural resources here that
are so so important to our livelihoods
from tourism to just basic you know
agricultural standards and you know we
have the Mississippi River running
through the state of Minnesota and
ignoring the facts and the studies of
climate change it's I mean it's just a
remarkable turn in humanity but it's
also out of step with what we need is
human one of his big drivet is Murray
energy they're one of the biggest coal
producers in the country but again
they're not in this state but they give
mr. Kline a lot of money and he protects
them that doesn't seem like the way the
founding fathers wanted our government
to work
okay I mean how do you defend this
environment testing in research is good
and I'm all for investing in accurate
legitimate science but the problem is
that it has not failed the test of an
audit there is a group are you really
serious international panel on climate
change this is a group of science
scientists that are from over fourteen
different countries they are
unaffiliated with any government or
political party which is why I like them
and they actually fact has fact-checked
all of this UN sanction science and
found that there is no evidence of human
human induced no where in your ass
you're pulling this out
somebody did a study of in the last ten
years
8150 eight peer-reviewed studies on
climate change all but two of over 8,000
agreed climate change was real and
man-made a lot of these scientists are
funded by the government they are these
are how ridiculous these talking points
sound in the year 2014 we debunked this
in what year 1990 we deeply debunked it
mr. mayor when we Tamar
very honestly if it were in the second
District of Minnesota
most of the mah er I just said no
premieres correct that's right
so so I apologize oh no I was kidding
you okay I was good nice day I hope you
were my friend here - about know about
mr. Marr we don't we don't treat women
like that in the second District
we'll get to how he treats you
I think when you take a look at these
issues we have all sorts of regulation
that goes on in the United States right
now and it's not smart regulation now
people aren't against regulation but
they're against over-regulation and
regulation that comes in a burdensome
way that doesn't give you the answer
that you need if you take a look at the
Keystone XL / I'm sorry rather polyMet
mine up in northern Minnesota they've
been under review for over six years
they've spent over two hundred million
dollars and they don't have an answer
now that's not effective that's not
efficient that's not right and we should
be able to get those folks an answer but
when we pivot back off of that we need
to take a look and address these issues
this isn't about whether or not we need
the climate we need another notion that
there have there is a definitive answer
about it and I'm not disagreeing with
that what I'm saying is that we need to
look for solutions now that means that
everything has to be on the tape whether
it's clean coal that Barack Obama
champion in 2010 for the new carbon
capture technology now scumming thing
but okay now nuclear research thing is
clean cold it's just we're up to speed
and if solar didn't have its back pocket
in Eric Schmidt's you know you know Eric
Schmidt has it got a 1.6 billion dollar
stimulus loan to build a huge it's solar
panel project out in the
california-nevada writer and he also
took 4,000 acres of public land to build
this solar project well the benefits
legitimate benefits of solar are that
it's clean and then it provides base
vote energy but I don't think a
billionaire like Google Google CEO
should have to get taxpayer dollars and
take four thousand acres of public land
and remove a desert tortoise in order to
do that he should do that by himself if
we want its horbet is but if we want to
talk about billionaires and corporations
getting tax credits maybe we should talk
about the subsidization of the oil
industry which
earth from the technology hey what's the
one mission they are not earth friendly
so what the mayor's it's Alondra we're
supposed to talk about what are we
supposed to talk about look huh to me
that's we fare too much Fox News there
Steve no you know just trying to be fair
and it's Solyndra in fairness is
important in any discussion is she what
she's talking about billionaires getting
subsidies we should talk about the
biggest picture of who's getting sales
what you and I could actually hurt okay
I know the business leaders in my city
are actively taking a look at these
issues because we all know we have to
plan for them in the future
I don't have you know I'm a mayor of a
city I have to think very pragmatically
very practically on the ground about
what we're going to be doing what kind
of you know water management are we
going to need in my city knowing that
it's going to be wetter and drier and
hotter and colder increasingly in the
years to come and if we set up if we set
ourselves up for it now maybe we can
manage it at the same time as we're
trying to prevent it from getting any
worse
what about this one against requiring
companies to disclose toxic chemicals
and drinking water what possible reason
I could could can't imagine what the
vote was maybe you can tell us what the
vote is against requiring companies in
school
chemicals in drinking water actually I'm
sure of the wording on these it really
is literally to outlaw the EPA from
doing this stuff like it is like that is
the wording especially on the one
regulating greenhouse gases it is to
prevent to legally prevent the
Environmental Protection Agency from
being able to enforce law that was to do
really smart because the EPA according
to an internal government probe in 2011
it was proved that the EPA fudged data
to get these coal regulations passed so
if you're fudging data you should not
even shocked that she gained a per
second because I'm going to talk about
that panel that you cited that was you
thought you talked about it was had some
scientists in it from said of whatever
how many countries there's at least for
2014 all right and 35 scientists that
and it was called it's funny it's called
the non-governmental International Panel
on Climate Change which is like one word
away from the International Panel on
Climate Change versus that it's like
it's like the bunch of nothing
yes it's intentional sort of like the
way the way that target likes to make
its brands like a lot like the real
brand but
like the stuff with the dollar school
like the olio poopsie cola
but so the real climate change panel had
500 scientists on it that were not paid
anything unlike this panel was sponsored
by the Heartland Institute
who actually there's a there was a leak
of documents from the Heartland
Institute that showed that they were
actually fundraising off of this report
well here's the thing science isn't
democratic it can take one scientist to
disprove everyone else
but scientists first of all the
scientists aren't in it for the money
the truth is not democratic which means
it takes more fruits out lay a lot of
light you know so there's something
called scientific consensus there will
always be one or two if this is you know
the theory of evolution do you believe
in it
yes I believe that there is some
evolution some evolution saw the
case-by-case basis well evolution is a
fact and but when it was proposed by
Darwin it took 50 years because in the
scientific method scientists challenged
it they wanted to see if it was real I
didn't believe it right away
people wrote papers for and against
after 50 years scientists agreed yes
we've tried to disprove this it hasn't
been disproved Darwin was right
evolution is real and then they moved on
to other subjects this is the state we
are in with climate change it's not a
matter of debate among scientists only
on fox news is it a matter of debate
it's the same way we did with evolution
and it is time to move on but
billionaire Tom Steyer who I know that
you have interviewed as well he has
these ads where he's talking about
climate change and he has admitted to
Time magazine I don't care about the
facts as much as pushing our culture in
the in the direction of embracing these
principles and being more earth friendly
well we can be more earth friendly
without believing in a myth the myth
being climate change humans cause
dangerous kind of change well where do
you think the carbon goes I mean this is
basic science that the earth just cannot
absorb this much Scarb in you know what
carbon is right I do I also know that um
you're against Keystone XL and because
that's putting more carbon in the
atmosphere that's incorrect according to
Time magazine which is not exactly a
conservative magazine you you release
more emissions into the air via
transporting crude via rail which you're
doing now than by a pipeline and that's
according to time yes there are worse
ways of doing it than what's in the
ground now you're right that doesn't
mean we should do it release the carbon
that's in the ground now the point about
fracking is that all that carbon that is
in the ground now that you want to put
in the air from pregnant that's that's
game over for the planet
so we're not releasing so many emissions
into the air in the first place at any
moment we could have derailment that
will kill children the answer the answer
oil spill was read outside of a
children's museum in Virginia that's
what I'm referring to
oh it's remarkable it's a remarkable
this is even a conversation it is
remarkable I mean it is remarkable how
come there are never arguments from
conservatives against things like
quantum mechanics or microbiology it's
always has to be some like industrial
pollution where there's a commercial
interest and because they don't get
because they don't get campaign
contributions from quantum exact I don't
think I don't think in Minnesota mr.
Maher we want to go down the road of
talking about where campaign
contributions come from when we look at
a governor Dayton running for
re-election and where he gets his money
we're not here to flip him or divisions
are only considered from one source not
don't know all services
I don't not from senator Franken who
gets all his money from outside
Minnesota either if you want to have a
flip Franken thing I'll come in and be
on the panel this is know you won't do
it because he's a liberal you won't do
that mr. mark well I do like Al Franken
yeah okay well that's one
this panel tonight is just about John
Klein's voting record there may be other
corrupt politicians in the state
mr. Klein is not corrupt well he won't
say absolutely not he takes me he takes
money from places mr. mostly from places
out of state that have nothing to do
with the needs of the people in the
state and then does their bidding in
Congress mr. his quorum is me
you call somebody prep you betters back
it up I just took mr. Meyer his common
client ever ever been charged with the
campaign ethics violation know that okay
points how do you get left with them the
scandal in this country is what's legal
not what's
he was guilty of illegalities I said he
will corrupt corrupt means when you take
money from people and corporation was
mostly corporations and do their bidding
instead of the bidding or before you or
any of those groups as well I am NOT
saying that he is the only corrupt
person in Congress well he's their
wallet would Ryan under your definition
under your definitional to a degree they
are to a degree they are
he's just the worst
let's take let's take this other major
contributor he has which is the
for-profit College industry penny
columns propriety colleges okay he is
voted against considering the Student
Loan Forgiveness Act he has voted to
raise rates on student loans to pay down
the deficit raised them from three point
four to five point nine percent takes
more money from for-profit colleges than
any member of Congress and his chairman
of the Education Committee has quashed
any attempts to regulate them why did
they need to be regulated well for
example his biggest contributor the
University of Phoenix
the online scam school has a graduation
rate of twelve percent eighty eight
percent of the people there don't
graduate that seems to me that would cry
out for some regulation the huge issue
with education in this country is that
it's the number one determinant for your
life expectancy that it correlates
income and education corley almost
entirely with how long you're expected
to live and so how well and how well
they while you're alive and how well you
are expected to live while you're live
it's like the Republican American Dream
is you know remain poor and die young
works in Minneapolis it doesn't work in
Kenya but let's go know what that means
is that that means is we're in the
second district we're not in Minneapolis
mayor we're not there now let's be fair
about this study there's a study that
was done and you can I can do your
slogan there too there's a study that's
been done of every single County in the
United States and what the life
expectancy is of those people in every
single County in the United States and
when you control for income and when you
control for education all the other
differences disappear all the other
differences disappear it's the number
one and it's certainly the one we can
change most education is the number one
determinant of your life expectancy
it was your slogan that there was an
argument there worker that was what
grossly ridiculous and inappropriate but
if you're talking about if you're
talking about what votes are taken and
what investments are made and what
policies are put forth and the impact
that they have on people's livelihoods
and their life expectancy if you're
against increasing availability of
health care if you are against you know
helping kids you need an education and
then helping people who have student
loan debt which I'm sure you want to
bring up at some point which is enormous
if you're against raising the minimum
wage if you are against protections for
workers if you're against unionization
all of these are things that point to
remain poor and die young
two jobs is a billionaire he created the
world's most baby and Rebecca was very
much and if he was very rich and so we
don't have to and he died young and the
Queen would be nation is different the
nation anecdotal information can always
if we took it seriously could disprove a
theory right there's always an outlier
there's always an exception I was
trained as a sociologist I think in big
categories and that's what the data
tells me well you're just needed good
yes yes yes couldn't risk it go ahead
I'm night we could lower the interest
rate down to zero and we would still be
having this discussion because what four
out of five seniors who graduate from
college are not able to tee themselves
up for a job if you can't get a job when
you graduate your student debt is going
to be much more of a problem so it's
interesting that first of all what our
seniors doing still in college college
seniors policy excuse me that's my
mistake
Janet say I've heard you know the six
year plan but you're exactly you're
exactly channeling the point why can't
these people get jobs because they're
going to these crappy diploma mill
acknowledges that better supporting
people like John Kline have to be rated
a bad economy just like Barack Obama
claims to have inherited a bad claim
okay great
so they both inherited a bad economy and
John F Kennedy after initially spending
a lot and against the wishes of his own
advisers after the spending wasn't
working he initiated mini tax cuts he
tipped his Federal Reserve to raise
raises so don't mind especially low well
a third of the stimulus program was tax
cuts then he lowered taxes for ninety
six brobama care bill and here's the
amazing thing between 2007 and 2013
there are only 110,000 jobs created from
Millennials between the ages of 22 and
34 at the same time well who was
president in 2007 attention and when
Obama took office we were losing 750,000
jobs a month
yes but Kennedy did not inherit an
economy anything like that in the state
of Colorado in 2012 the industry of
fracking created 111 thousand jobs so
that means that one industry one space
serial killers create jobs and morgues
it doesn't mean that we should
yes could we go to the issue that you're
talking about at this please do stoop
this is student loan and and again I
only want to be fair I know you did know
I and I know you do and in just yo
people can disagree about issues but
from facts and by the way if I could say
something for this panel it's not really
fair for you three that the audience is
against you and I appreciate
where the whole audience was against my
point of view it's not easy so we do
appreciate you little friends in the
front row decided that they're still
friends I finally track whether a new
trick to the issue at hand right and now
to be fair though just take me ten
seconds fifteen Nancy Pelosi in 2007
passed the suit loan bill that
artificially kept the rate of 3.4% her
bill was four year cliff for bill was
going to double to 6.8% in 2011 she
doubled the student rate flow that was
her bail then in 2012 election year they
came forward to Congress and decided
election year we better do something
about the student loan play for the
political football with it so they
artificially kept it low again it's at
three point four percent costing the
Treasury or tossing our budget deficit
six million dollars mr. Obama my
president your president came forward
with a needed suggestion in 2013 says we
want to do this we want to do the
student loan program so it's not a
political football so that we do it in a
long-term structurally sound basis and
John Klein led that bipartisan effort in
the Senate in the house and with the
president the president when he signed
the bill who did he give credit to mr.
mark I don't know he gave credit to John
Klein to chairman Kline is what he says
in signing that bill but that brought
structure that brought reasonableness
and brought some long term plan into
student loans you're going down the
wrong path in this issue if you study
the only the issue isn't the interest
the interest is the principal it's how
much college costs that's the real
I apply to college is remain expensive
because these awful colleges like like
the University of Phoenix like Capella
University because there they're not
regulated they are allowed to receive
federal Stafford loans yeah we have to
go in and make sure that anybody that
actually receives a federal loan there
is a real college nobody-nobody Matt
Matt nobody wants nobody wants a
non-performing school so there should be
investing but how come so many of the
numbers a lot Matt to be very honest to
talk about the student loans which we're
talking about but John Kline has
received accolades from stakeholders
from the colleges from Student
Association from Democrats John Klein's
bill a hundred and seventy one House
Democrats voted for the bipartisan bill
thirty-five Democratic senators voted
for the bill you cannot go after John
Klein on this issue yes well no you can
he puts a really tough Kim UW the press
the facts are against you mr. Meyer
we're talking about eight actually
explicitly for-profit education which is
just a horrible terrible it's just I'm
gonna disagree with you on that issue
I'm gonna disagree I'm sorry so student
loans
it's like for-profit education industry
wouldn't exist without special student
loans ninety percent of students in fact
in for-profit colleges have student
loans have federal student loans they
have the lowest rates of graduation they
the lowest rates of employment they have
the most students who are in poverty if
they're going to for-profit colleges
veterans and these are his biggest
campaign contributors have acknowledged
that preyed upon veterans because
they're the people who are exempted from
this idea that for-profit college should
have at least ten percent that doesn't
come from federal student loans they
discount GI Bill beneficiaries I mean I
mean if we are going to prepare our
workers we're going to prepare our
workforce from a development standpoint
for the future and President Obama has
made this President Obama has made this
is greatest one of the
greatest challenges we need proprietary
schools we need to colleges we need the
U of M we need Carleton we need sing-off
we need them all if we're going to
prepare the students to make it
specifically about veterans who are
there's corruption out of their GI bill
education by for profits by by night
all sides I own we probably need term
limits and John Klein is running for his
seventh term so that there's a question
there about you don't think you should
be reluctant more jobs more Millennials
would be running we'd have some fresh
blood in here but be um we have to look
at the fact that um youth are you
mentioned that the government is
involved you mentioned that the
government is involved and that that is
good I guess
but the fact is if we were to get them
you know it's not I don't think I'm
saying that at all I'm not a supporter
of these colleges to blow their their
tuition because they know our students
can get student loans but that's what
that's what Klein is fighting for I
think what he's trying to tell you is
that the for-profit college is only 13%
of the entire college population goes to
the for-profit colleges but their
response were 50 percent of the loans
for America a 20% of loan defaults
rather all your student defaults that's
what makes everybody's rates go long
though that is what allows the colleges
to blow to the overall tuition rate
rather than having it more privatized
and Barack Obama himself proposed a
budget that would tie student interest
rates to the market but exactly and then
there was a Lincoln's proposed the same
thing and then he changed isn't it but
you're aware that the government makes a
huge profit on student loans yes 50
million 50 billion dollars okay
John Klein wants to pay down our deficit
with that money from students it seems
like there's so many better places we
could find that money but but again he
wants to get rid of the estate tax he
wants to get rid of everything that
would make the peep the rich people pay
and let's the whole state tax really
quickly is I know that you're not from
ii don't know it that well you thought
it was kind of suburbs of Minneapolis
but there's a huge agricultural market
in the second District that estate tax
hits those family farms incredibly hard
to the point where we're seeing farms
that are having to leave families that
it's been in for generations because
they can't afford to pay theist
tax in this economy right now that's not
just something that impacts billionaires
and millionaires this is something that
affects small farmers which happened to
be a big part of this district okay any
college any college should be held
accountable for his performance
proprietary or not any college
when it gets to the issue of the student
loan when it gets to the issue at hand
that mr. Marr brada that the student
loan bill that passed in 2000 wasn't
this year 14th or ism that maybe was 13
john kline led the bipartisan effort
what's John time Mary Ann we've gone
over these luck that Ubuntu another
Amanda's not except tonight okay school
has a 12 percent graduation yeah we know
that we've gone by then they should be
held accountable
John we're going around in circles I'm
going to go to our last issue which is
about women mostly but also lets the
throw in same-sex in this he is for John
Kline for defunding Planned Parenthood
he has a zero percent voter rating from
Planned Parenthood by the way he has 0%
rating from the environmental raiders
also on Michelle Bachmann who doesn't
think carbon is harmful as an 11
voted to make abortion illegal after 20
weeks and make doctors who perform them
eligible for up to five years in prison
co-sponsored a bill exempting forcible
rape but not rape from a ban on federal
funding of abortion so again that number
Todd akin legitimate rape he's another
person apparently wants to make
distinctions about rape against the
equal pay for women and against the
lilly Ledbetter Fair Pay Act against
prohibiting job discrimination based on
sexual orientation for the Defense of
Marriage Act
that's against obviously gay marriage
and against the repeal of Don't Ask
Don't Tell in the military is this in
step with the voters here yes
I'm dying man John
you all
that's that's that's not you
he'll you be respected there's
differences of opinion yes and there are
you really respect that you understand
that there's going to be differences of
value I said if there's differences of
principles absolutely
but the strengthen democracy this only
strength of our our country our Republic
is that people will come together and
they'll compromise and that's the only
strength if we don't if we go that we've
lost well then we've lost the country
because a republic cannot survive race
there's a willingness to cooperate and
compromise now I don't know whether the
government is the best answer the best
solution for these problems does the
government help us become more equal I
think Thomas Jefferson would tell us you
don't need the federal government I
would think the slaves would do your
most intimate personal relationships and
we made a mistake long ago of involving
the federal government in heterosexual
marriage we should get the federal
government out of all marriage there
should not be any federal involvement in
that at all and that and that would
allow anyone who wanted to get married
to get married
so you're for a gay marriage I am for
yes states and individuals deciding just
no federal why what is it what's the
difference between Utah and
Massachusetts if two people want to get
married what people get married
differently yes my question is what's
the government have to gain from giving
us different tax rates depending on
whether or not you're married or not why
is the government involved in marriage
in the first place I couldn't agree more
here's the other thing but you do but
I've never been about any abortion issue
Yeah right right right right all in law
no that should be a decision between a
woman and her doctor' yeah let's it Roe
vs. Wade I grew up in that world that's
the world that I live in reality is that
we should not what people in this
district are talking about right now
yeah it's when you take a look around
people are well about whether or not
they can get that job that's a little
bit better whether or not they may be or
not propagated maybe you're not talking
for sexually active people who don't
want their doctor to go to jail for
performing an abortion maybe some people
are talking about what you just said
speaks directly to this issue because
women to want to say I want to get the
next best job I want to make sure that I
can move forward and I want to make sure
when I get there discrimination doesn't
happen in a way that either makes me
leave the job because I have I see
myself with fewer options or I don't get
paid the same amount on that job or that
my options are curtailed and women
should absolutely be paid the same for
the same work
it's 1963 my car it seems like we found
an area where the right part of the
panel is really not with John Clum
you're for gay marriage I'm here for
abortion
let's look at the common ground there
though let's look at the common training
you've got to find some common ground ok
gotta find people coming together let's
find it right or wrong and I understand
many disagree I respect that okay what
about this issue both of them have been
decided on the ballot box and
referendums in Minnesota the in 2012 the
issue went down in California I think in
2008 or 10 incorrect it passed if I
remember correctly which are my gay
marriage yes
no that went down in 2000 and went down
allowing that wearing it here it went
down that was prohibited wasn't in 2000
problems of value it was an effort so we
were the first we wer the first date
okay yes but even with Madison to time
just talking about whether decline is it
right pay for equal work
that's been the law since 1963 did
anybody try to repeal the Equal Pay Act
of 1963
I'm absolutely opposed to all lads to
try to say that women need the
legislation to help us in the workplace
that's absolutely untrue because there's
a nuke you pull out that just do not go
and wear 2013 what is it then hey equity
is the law I don't know the legislation
to solve this problem is what I'm saying
because in but why are women paid less
okay yours let me just go to second one
is cute
oh man even if we grant you that point
which I don't even if I grant you that
point that in this day and age
Millennials don't need legislation the
only reason you don't need legislation
which I don't agree with is because
there was legislation
let's go Katy the ploy we are at near
parity with men and isn't so there's a
very small gap but there is closing Yap
here's what needs to happen women needs
to stop being bi TCH s to each other
I stand with you
for spelling out that or same time just
came up with a study that showed that
women in the workplace in business
negotiations blatantly lie to other
women and also women are far more likely
to promote and mentor young male
associates I didn't read that to ya
study that would close that smell that
that those differences disappear the
more women there are in a workplace
yes a woman is the only senior partner
or the only senior in a higher situation
she will grab a torch to hiring men and
not women if you put more women in that
scene you're hiring position they will
be more likely to hire women we have
there a lot more women to wear che so in
these studies are ok not enough what
we're running on time I have one last
question I want to ask about the subject
we're talking about which is congressman
Kline which is why doesn't he appear the
biggest surprise I said was we thought
when it came to October which is the
last month before the campaign campaign
season we thought he'd be somewhere
every day I mean when guys run for
president they're out there on the
hustings 18 hours a day he hasn't
appeared in public since August 17th
there's one on TV notoya delivers right
now tonight he spends this as
firefighters month is now I think it's
with firefighters right now that we
can't find him we can wait truck we've
tried to have people go to find him to
ask a question to present some of these
facts to him some of these issues say
what is your position on this why do you
back this why do you say this he's not
around it's like he's in the witness
protection
I would think that this would seem to be
insulting to the voters of this district
that his strategy to win is just to hide
not to anybody the election are you on I
want to know
there's John
I'm excited mr. Meyer if you were
talking about John Klein or Al Franken
or Mark Dayton I didn't know which money
because they also have refused from
prime time debate that may be the case
I don't care is the case it is a case I
know that to be but that doesn't really
defend John Klein why doesn't John Klein
appear and I think those other guys
probably do but okay that they appear
but not at prime time but not prime time
you know seven o'clock night was solely
hammer time
if I go after a cheerful and really
little yeah I'm sorry so first of all
your claim that he hasn't had a public
event is just simply not true
there was actually a story today and the
stars being our largest newspaper in the
state they happen to find him you know
district but they didn't seem to have
any trouble finding him they ran a
profile they said here he was he was
hanging out an event he was accessible
he didn't go and force himself into
conversations but he was there he was
successful he's always been accessible
do you know no town halls no debates
he's met the designers to your point
about the with eights there's a debate
on her being firefighters okay all right
we'll just afraid there's a good guy
seemed of the lady can I call ad next
time we can't find him can I call you
you sure
it seems like you know when they want to
find Superman they got to go through
Clark Kent
we have to get a home to John Klein no
one can find it can we put you on the
speed dial
all right well listen again thank you
guys for doing this I know this was not
an easy gig for you how about a hand for
the right